i'm so cool i cannot help the coolness  start the day gabby's gonna teach you  how to hit a bit listen if this is what  we're getting into that's what we're  getting okay i'm like [ __ ]  yeah don't don't mess with me boom my  problem is the like  like it's like  you need to keep it tight let me like  practice the fact that i  am a lover not a fighter  i don't know how to fight  i know people that are like actual  fighters i don't know about all that  okay okay all i know is if i'm hitting a  [ __ ] i'm here okay boom oh i can't get  tight and i'm going like boom oh okay  okay i never took your thumb because  that's how you break your thumb oh okay  oh no  i'm killing it  oh like this just looks so weak  but us we're getting out of bed before  noon today  we never do that  ever  all right so what happens we're in a  club okay  what happens a girl goes like this to  you